One day a friend of Mr. Murdstone's came to stay.
His name was Mr. Quinion, and he had a bottle factory in London and offered me a job.
"I'm sending you to do something useful," said Mr. Murdstone.
The next day, neither sad nor happy,...
...I left my little home on my way to the big world outside.
I am not easily surprised nowadays,...
...but it made me think about how I was sent away from school at the age of ten to work.
I started my work at the factory of Murdstone and Grinby.
On that first day, I met a man called Mr. Micawber.
He became my landlord.
He collected me from work and took me through the backstreets to his house.
He introduced me to his wife and their four children:...
...twins who were still nursing, a four-year-old boy, and a three-year-old girl.
They were very poor and had many creditors.
The creditors used to come knocking on the door very early,...
...and they shouted at Mr. Micawber to come out. He never did.
He used to say,...
"If you earn twenty shillings a year and spend nineteen, you will be happy."
"If you earn twenty shillings a year and spend twenty-one, you will be unhappy,"...
...but he never followed these words.